what's going on everyone happy uh hump
day wednesday
uh i want to make this quick video for
you uh because i'm gonna be sharing some
of the lessons that i did from
that i got from a uh uh 500 million
dollar mastermind but it was basically
eight people
eight entrepreneurs who together were
doing uh over 500 million dollars a year
i was the second smallest so we'll we'll
finish this year i think at 32 million
um i think there was one guy at like
seven um
and then but everybody and then another
one was at around my 35
and then the rest of them were almost
all above 100 and we had one guy over
250.
and the biggest i'll tell you the two
biggest takeaways
that i have from that entire experience
the big the first one was when i looked
at the biggest
of them they sold
simple right uh simple scales
and so the term that i've given myself
to like remember this is scale zero
which is i have to get my business to a
point where there's literally
zero requirement of me zero
not like eat like zero none as in like
it just keeps going and growing
and by getting to that point
where it requires zero then
i can scale it without becoming the
bottleneck
and so let me see if i can unpack this
in
a useful way for everyone like right now
if you're doing anything within the
business if you were to double the
business the question is are you going
to have to double the amount of stuff
that you do
many times it's a yes and to be honest
with you it takes a long time to get
like you're going to move up the skill
set like in the beginning you do
everything and then you're going to
outsource some administrative work and
then you're going to outsource some you
know
back-end customer service work and then
you're going to outsource the sales and
then
and then you'll start outsourcing maybe
the marketing and then after that you'll
you know maybe outsource the messaging
behind your overarching position
in the marketplace but at some point
literally the only thing that should be
left for you to do is just make
decisions
and not all decisions but just the
biggest and most important decisions
right
and so if that is what is left for you
to do then there's basically
zero right and so scaling zero
means that for me to get bigger i must
get smaller within the company
i must become less and less and less
important
to the company's success in order for
the company to grow without me being the
bottleneck of it
and i think that um this has just been
such so incredibly telling
uh for me going through this and
watching each of them
uh what the people who are doing more
than me how
how little they were doing and that's by
design that's deliberate it's hard to do
that
and you fail a lot and you hire people
and they mess up and you eat those costs
of mistakes but
that's why you know finding really good
people is important but scaling
zero has been my the the brand like the
branding that i'm trying to send into my
brain it's like scale zero
like get yourself down to zero because
only then i'll be able to scale
otherwise if i'm doing 20 hours a week
of work and we double that i'll be at 40
right and so that has been
probably one of the biggest lessons the
next lesson
that i learned was that from just about
everybody else there and mind you the
lessons that i'm sharing with you now
are the lessons that i'm
learning in my current chapter my
current season you may not be in this
season but i
want to be transparent with you that
this is what i'm learning right now
and the lesson that i learned
was that everybody else was going after
a bigger marketplace than i was
and so they were all wildly impressed
that we've been able to you know
generate a hundred million dollars in a
single niche
but they're like man you know you're
really good at this stuff
you should be going after multiple you
just go after a bigger market like
you're in a pond they're like or a lake
you should be going after the ocean and
so that was what i saw was consistent
between all of them
was that they were all in oceans and i
was in a lake
and so that was probably the biggest the
second biggest takeaway
um that i had the third biggest takeaway
here's a bonus one for you is that
everything that everyone
sold there was simple um and i'm gonna
say simple in two different ways one
is that of everyone there i was the only
one who had three businesses
terrible idea um i mean we've i've i've
learned my lessons and we've been able
to
build it but i had to take steps
backwards and really work myself to
death in order to get all three of them
you know over eight and multi-figures in
order to to to work
right but i feel like i lost probably
two years of development for myself as
an entrepreneur because
i split my attention and every single
other person there
had one business that they were focused
on and more specifically
one customer and so um that was a big
lesson for me
now you can have multiple businesses but
for just about everybody who's listening
to this you're probably not that
at that level like and i'm and i'm not
saying that
you know douchely but like if you're
buying a business
that's very different than you starting
multiple of them and being ceo of them
all
if you have multiple businesses and this
is a mistake that i made early on and a
mistake that i've made
again later on if you're ceo
of all of them you do like you it's
for just about every human besides elon
musk it's not feasible
and so every other person that i know
makes who's made a tremendous amount of
money made it in one vehicle
and then they may own pieces of other
businesses
right and if they are the main owner in
in multiple businesses which is rare
but if they are the main owner in those
businesses they are not a partner
they're not an active partner
in that business they've hired a ceo
they've hired an executive team
that can run and grow that business
without them um but
i remember hearing that when i was
younger it was like oh man this guy has
all these companies
he doesn't own all the companies that
he's like he's not in it
right he's not in any of them he's got
teams of executives and high level
producers who are incentivized usually
with some
level of equity in that company and he
advises strategically
um and so that was you know again
one of the reminders we need to be
reminded more than we need to be taught
myself included um that one of the
mistakes that i was making that everyone
else there was not and so
i'll recap it for you because i'm doing
it for myself too the first was
scaling zero i have to get down to zero
in order to scale otherwise i'll be the
bottleneck
the second was going after oceans
instead of lakes um again remember this
is me at my season
if you're if you're starting out going
after a lake is not a bad idea which is
why
me making the decision to just niche
down to a single you know niche of gyms
was not a bad
decision because it was the right call
at that time now we've developed a skill
set
that we you know now we've helped
agencies in 100 plus niches generate
clients for their clients and so
i feel very adept at that skill
third is focusing on one main business
as your primary vehicle
and an interesting thing that i found
out recently was the word the
the root of the word etymology behind
the word decide decision
um so c day like suicide patricide
matricide side is to kill homicide right
it's
kill and so a decision is where you
choose to kill off all the
all other things so you you select by
elimination
right which i kind of like that so it's
like when you decide you're actively
choosing to kill off other things and
so you need to decide what your business
is going to be and kill off all other
options
and so that is the the third lesson
um that i got from all of those those
people here
that were at that mastermind and the and
the fourth one
um was every single one of them was
selling a tremendously high margin
gross gross margin um service and or
product
except for one of them uh and the two
people who were selling the lowest
margin stuff were the smaller businesses
and so
when i heard that it was really it was
challenging for me in a good way
of thinking like how can we provide
value in bigger ways
for less hard costs to us as business
owners and risk
and so as i think about you know the
next moves that i'll do in my
entrepreneurial career i'm taking those
things into consideration so
it's what am i going to do that is going
to go after an ocean
instead of a lake what am i going to do
that's going to be just one thing so not
lots of things attacking the ocean just
one
what thing is going to be you know very
high margin but very high value which is
difficult a lot of times you can you can
do
high margin but low hopefully you get
what i'm saying here
i want a high a high margin thing that
is high value
um and sometimes that's hard to find and
then finally
i want to structure it in such a way
that i can get it to the point where i
am not the bottleneck of the business
because i have
um better better decision making leaders
so not just
not just like in the beginning you have
doers and then you have managers and
then you have leaders and then you have
decision makers
and leaders to a certain degree are
getting into that it depends on what
level of leadership
but really finding high level people who
have the experience of doing this thing
in the past they've already run and won
the olympic gold i don't want to teach
someone how to do it i want someone
who's already done it
and can just plug right in and comes
pre-loaded with the solutions they come
batteries included um as uh as maxwell
says
and so um anyways those are the biggest
findings um that i had now looking back
three months later after the dust has
settled from that
half a billion dollar mastermind and
those are the lessons that i took away
from it so
i hope that was valuable for you if you
want the the inner
the inner secrets of what what's
happening behind the scenes in those in
those types of rooms um
those are the types of conversations
that we're having and i hope you found
that valuable and i'll see in the next
vid